Britain's National Health Service is
experiencing its longest waiting times
on record as tests and treatments put on
hold through the pandemic work their way
through the system on Monday thousands
of appointments have been postponed for
the public holiday of the Queen's
funeral I had an appointment canceled on
Monday so I came up today and I think
that's that's fine I'm glad that they
were able to see me at a different time
so quickly if I was a cancer patient I'd
be really really upset
and I do understand why because everyone
wants to pay their respect to the queen
I don't know what the right answer is
I've just had my blood done because I
didn't think they'd be open on Monday
um I think it's very unfortunate that
that's happened
emergency treatments and Urgent
procedures will still go ahead as
planned but reduced Staffing means many
other appointments will be hit family
doctor appointments will also suffer
with many medical centers shut for the
day obviously as NHS is obliged to go by
the national holidays at the same time
we have to look after our patients so we
are sort of Stuck in the Middle where we
have to both respect the public opinion
as well as the government opinion for
example and so I think you know it's
probably a very difficult situation that
the NHS is in at the moment and as the
country prepares for the Queen's funeral
others are being put on hold funeral
director Francis Alcock has seen one
planned ceremony on Monday postponed the
fear it would be overshadowed and that
people might not come she says she's
heard of other families especially those
who've booked cremations having funerals
canceled against their Wishes the
feeling is that you know if it's their
mum that's died their mum is more
important to them than the queen however
much they love the queen and because of
the Monumental grief around it's sort of
taken away
some of the sort of I suppose how they
feel they can grieve for an event on
this scale one day of national pause
will widely be seen as appropriate but
for those who've been negotiating the
delays and backlogs of a covid hit
Health Service that one day could have
been a much prized knee surgery or
cancer treatment at the very least it's
a reminder that the multiple problems
this government faces will remain after
the morning period ends and they'll need
to be dealt with Harry Fawcett Al
Jazeera London
a powerful typhoon